[Music]
Katrien you are an actress yes you are a
director uh-huh
producer now screenwriter yeah I guess
you can actually say all those things
and they're true you're a good evil
threat girl
I have Wow that's it's weird because
this is my first feature film that's
been produced and is you can actually
say those things yeah Oh fresh off
pretty little liars
Troian Bellisario can now add writer to
her resume she penned and starred in
feed a project that hit close to home
look sick
to eat don't I need that been very
candid about the struggles that you've
gone through it was it easy an easy
decision to put yourself in that role or
did you have some hesitancy definitely I
definitely had some hesitancy a lot of
people who loved me had a lot of
hesitancy yeah like why but I think it
was really important for me I
particularly in writing it I felt a
cathartic experience because as I
progressed further and further in my
recovery I got to examine the illness
you know from from a greater perspective
yeah now jumping into the role and
enacting it I was you know I think I had
a lot of naivete about just mean like
yeah I got this you know that was like
years ago yeah and then all of a sudden
I was like oh wow this has just been
living under the surface and it was
really important to I think reengage in
those conversations and and to be open
and to be vulnerable and to continue to
talk to you know my therapist and my
family and say wow I'm really struggling
with doing this and even struggling with
putting this story out there you know
and my mom was really wonderful when she
spoke to me about it and she said you
know I love you and I loved you through
your illness but I didn't understand it
yeah until I read your script Wow so I'm
really excited he's gonna see the vote
she's nervous and I'm nervous for her to
see it even though this is not my story
it's very personal yeah and she suffered
through it in her own way next to me but
for her to say to me I understood it for
the first time after reading your script
yeah that to me was what made it worth
everything
[Music]